we have learned from a source close to
vend that his drinking problem
had become life and death yet Ben was
back home again today away from rehab
doing better Ben do I think that Ben's
serious about his recovery absolutely
not not with these reports that means
he's just going through the motions to
get people off his back 8:30 this
morning Ben left the treatment center to
play a three-hour game of basketball
he returned to rehab after this time
there was no sign of Shauna Sexton the
22 year old Playboy model who was
arrested for underage drinking in 2014
and last year for public intoxication
was spotted out in Ben's Ford Expedition
after spending time with him yesterday
Shauna addressed her party-girl image
and those arrests in an Instagram post
writing do these mistakes mean I would
disrespect someone's hard-earned
sobriety by drinking with them or in
front of them
hell no addiction expert Howard Samuels
who is not treating Ben is concerned
he's totally manipulating the rehab any
good rehab would never allow anybody to
go home and work out let alone see
somebody who's 22 years old who has her
own issues with alcohol
so how has Ben's ex handling all this
well Jen garner who you'll recall drove
been to rehab 15 days ago was spotted
out today in New York she's been smiling
and keeping a brave face as she promotes
her butt-kicking role and peppermint out
tomorrow
however a source tells us that Jen was
aware Ben spent time with Shana and is
painfully frustrated but deep down quote
she knows he has to do this for himself
my advice to Jen to set your boundaries
and if he relapses or he uses he has to
be banned from seeing the kids or being
around them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]